What do you think?
Uh,
um,
my arms,
I'll have you know that I'm really good at lip reading.
Okay.
Then I'll just talk like this.
My name is Peter Sundar,
so I am 26
and I'm Bethany Strobel and I'm 25,
seven years.
Yeah.
Can you hear what I'm saying?
Okay.
You,
you can't,
oh,
she can't hear anything.
Uh,
the first time I saw her was actually on the Internet.
Yeah.
I saw her on a website called the lookbook Dutton new and um,
I think she commented on one of my pictures.
So I clicked on it and uh,
I saw her and my goodness,
I mean,
don't point at me and makes me nervous.
The first time I met her I was,
uh,
we,
we met for a photo shoot and um,
we were just hanging out and as I was leaving,
she offered to cook for me when she was like,
I'm not going to let you to leave on an empty stomach.
I was like,
that's the one.
Oh,
my ears are ringing.
Yeah.
Okay.
We were both doing this site called lookbook.
I liked his,
um,
outfit.
And then I think I commented or something.
I thought he was cute.
I Dunno.
Yeah.
He came over to do like this photo shoot or something and like I invited this
random guy to my house and what he's saying,
but we had been talking for a while and I was,
I was slow to like make a decision or like even think in that way.
It took me a few months to like really think that,
oh,
maybe I do want to be with this guy.
Okay.
I wasn't sure if she liked me or not cause I told her like a week before that I
liked her and she just kind of like,
okay.
And acted as if nothing happened.
And uh,
so I just kind of like made the leap to try to kiss her.
And as I went in and she like,
Woo dodged it
and I was like,
oh,
wrong.
Did Not read the signals.
Right.
He
went in for a kiss and I was like,
Oh God.
And like really freaked out at first,
but then I kissed him.
So it made up for it.
Did you,
I dodged it.
And then I was like,
okay,
yeah,
Manny Castillo.
I always,
I don't remember all of them.
I was like,
I went in and you were like,
I thought,
I always thought I made the first move.
I guess it's not really an insecurity,
it's more of a fear that she will be taken on like a really long job away if he
gets like a big movie or something.
I don't know.
She was the first,
um,
I guess non Asian that I've had a relationship with and at first that was
something that I was like really insecure about.
We haven't really gotten into like a really bad fight.
Um,
parenting together is
sort of difficult.
She,
she has a daughter.
So,
um,
I think the hardest part is the way people look at us more than anything.
Like we personally don't have a problem with it.
We,
I got into the relationship knowing she had a kid,
I was 16,
so you can imagine there were
hard times,
but he was there like about a year after she was born.
And he's been there ever since.
So
she doesn't want her,
her dishes.
I always have to wash your dishes and if you asked her,
she'd be like,
I'm working on it.
I've been washing the dishes for the past two weeks and she has been,
but still,
it's like washing dishes.
I'm
going to say that I wash my dishes.
Yeah,
you do sort of.
He's actually a really great dancer and I never really tell him that,
but he is very sexy when he dances.
But as for personality wise,
what I find the most sexy is his honesty and trustworthiness.
I really like her shoulders.
I know why.
I know that's a weird,
weird thing to say.
I love her personality.
I sexiest thing about her.
The fact that she could do this stupid faces and doing little jokes like that.
She did.
He said it first.
I did.
I thought she was sleeping and I said to her,
I think I'm falling in love with you.
I think she pretended to be asleep for that whole duration.
She don't want to say it back.
Yeah.
And you admitted it like a week later.
I remember I said,
uh,
I think I'm falling in love with you.
Oh yeah,
I do.
Yeah.
Well,
I didn't know what to say.
I know.
So you just present them to sleep?
Yeah,
maybe I don't tell them enough,
but I have told him that I'm really proud of him,
just proud of who he is.
We've been together for a really long time and I'm really proud of him.
I've never felt this way about another person.
So he is my
home.
Wherever he is,
I'm 100% comfortable and I feel safe.
Yeah.
Actually,
I wish you would love yourself like I love you or you at least you would love
yourself like you love me.
I chose you because you are the purest human being I've ever met.
You always make things lighter for me.
Whether I'm sad,
anxious,
stressed,
you're always there for me.
I need you actually need you.
We've got so serious.
I almost cried.
I know.
I saw that.
I was like,
why you keep cases were just talking about
thanks.
I just said that.
I'm proud of you,
but I do tell you that,
but maybe not enough.
Thank you.
Oh,
all I said was,
I wish you would love yourself as much as I loved you.
Loved past tense.
As much as I love you.
I love you.
I love you too.
That's it.
You could tell me all the bad things he said when we get in the car or you can
watch it on youtube.
I'm not going to wait that long.
We didn't cry.
My mic fell down.
Thank you.
Thank you for having us.